hey guys welcome back to new rock stars
is the channel we've got every sort of
nerdy breakdown you could ever wish for
my name is Sam bachelor and I'm here
with an Avengers infinity war teaser
Todd legacy that was uploaded to
Marvel's YouTube and social media
accounts and it's got some juicy details
about the movie that I need to dig in to
use your spoiler warning I guess if you
didn't know that there might be spoilers
in this video I can't help you let's get
going for the most part the majority of
this footage has been seen already but
let's look closer at the new stuff
specifically the opening shot with
Thanos and his Black Order now if you
need an explainer for who these
characters are Eric did a few videos on
this channel about them and they're very
good I actually watch them before I made
this video to make sure I didn't mess up
too bad looks like the black order is
sending in the wreckage of a room of a
battle with their father / leader tdawg
or the big t if you will and if you'll
notice t-bird has at least two Infinity
stones the space stone and the power
stone now we see tdawg holding up his
arm into the air surrounded by either
severely wounded or a dead people with
what looks to be the energy from the
Power Stone swirling throughout the room
now the following clip we see the power
stone lit up and based on some crafty
research by Eric it looks like these
stones illuminate when they are being
activated when they're being used his
visual of Thanos closing his fist to
activate the stone seems like a similar
visual to Thanos snapping his fingers in
the comics all he's gotta do is simply
close this fist to just show how
powerful he is he annihilates an entire
roomful of people now after watching
this clip over and over again until my
eyes wouldn't close no more I have a
theory about how this whole scene
actually plays out I think this is out
of order my guess is that this energy
surging throughout the room is a result
of Thanos activating the stones through
this move based on the firepower we've
seen the power stone unleashing
guardians the galaxy vol 1 this baby
could easily kill a roomful of people as
supposed to annihilate whole planets
based on what we've seen so far from the
other trailers this scene looks an awful
lot like the wreck as guardianship so
this could possibly be the end of the
Asgardian race hope not cuz I'd be a
bummer
based on this clip and the other clips
of the guardians the Galaxy teaming up
with Thor I have a rough idea of how
this story could play out that
specifically the story of the guardians
in Thor
meeting for the first time here's my
theory Thanos NAB's himself the Power
Stone
from the Nova Corps ons and are and
things probably don't go so great for
the Nova's they probably reach out for
some help and boom the Guardians the
galaxies are on the case this doesn't
stop our big dog though because he's on
a mission and heads to the next closest
infinity stone which is the space stone
which we know is in possession of the
one and only Loki a former Asgard this
leads to our confrontation and eventual
annihilation of the Asgardian people
probably the death of Loki and Thor
being tossed out into space don't worry
too much about the god of thunder the
guardians have been following Thanos
tracks and arrived a little late to stop
Thanos but are able to grab Thor and
bring him aboard probably this is what
I've got so far let's see if I'm right
in two weeks but from there we see our
montage of previous Marvel films which
is either just meant to be a little
representation of Toni's line it's all
been leading to this or maybe it's a
tease to a theory that's been floating
around on the internet more on that in a
second but now some more infinity war we
see Fano Siskiyou ship over new york
wreaking some havoc then we get the
previously released shots of Black Widow
in Wakanda Tony with Hulk strange and
Wong in New York probably looking at the
cue ship Thor rocket and Groot in space
spider-man with his iron spider suit on
the cue ship and an overhead shot of
Thanos his army of the outriders
attacking an energy barrier right
outside of Wakanda the next clip is up
Steve Rogers aka Nomad in this movie
attacking the outriders based on one of
the first trailers of infinity war this
looks like just a continuation of that
fight scene we then see the whole gang
charging into battle in Wakanda you got
black panther mbaku Okoye a war machine
Winter Soldier Black Widow Steve Rogers
and the Hulkbuster suit which probably
houses Bruce Banner inside the next shot
is the sideways look at the charging
army but why are they charging my guess
is that the world wars the Esk wave of
outriders attacking the energy barrier
needs to be stopped ASAP that makes
sense right mm-hmm so we know based on
this trailer and toys and random
insurance commercials that Tony's armor
is gonna have all the bells and whistles
you could possibly want for Ironman
well you're gonna need them all to fight
Thanos and the black order but I don't
think he's the only hero that has an
upgrade for the field check out this
over the shoulder shot of war machine
flying over the battlefield in Wakanda
he's got his Gatling guns less railgun
over his shoulder and he got an arm
cannon right down there but check out
his little wing design on his back is
this kind of similar to Tony's armor
maybe with the new arms bringing it back
around to this scene star-lord is aiming
higher
than his Island meaning that wherever
this villain is as adversary is taller
than him which could only really be two
villains one being Thanos because he's
like nine feet tall he's enormous but
also this could be they Deeb you or solo
adventure of one of the members of the
black horror that we really haven't seen
in the trailer too much coal obsidian
aka the biggest boy in the Black Order
well moving on we get the same shot of
Scarlet Witch in Proxima midnight
fighting in front of an explosion as
well as the shot of Doctor Strange being
tortured by ebony mom oh no so sad but
the next shot is very intriguing for
just a few frames we see Shuri working
on a hologram which we know that one of
her missions in this movie is to assist
vision after he's been attacked by the
Black Order my guess is that she's
trying to study the mine stone the best
she can but also maybe she's trying to
figure out a way to remove it from
vision based on her expression though
she seems pretty awfully stressed
hopefully she can help our pink
synthezoid out that'd be awesome
next we get a shot of Loki handing over
the tesseract again we've seen this
before but I have a question for you do
you think Loki is hidden over this as a
bargaining chip like maybe he could
prove to Thanos that he still could be a
good assistant honestly I don't think
Loki's gonna make it very far in this
movie but scoots you forward to one of
the clearest shots of one of the members
of the Black Order Proxima midnight ooh
check out her right here fighting
Scarlet Witch now I'm guessing that this
is from the fight we mentioned
previously and I'm really digging her
character designed very similar to the
comics and seeing her go toe-to-toe with
the Scarlet Witch is gonna make me ever
so excited in the theaters locking her
spear with a telekinesis ball chaos
magic from the comics if you want to
call it that next we had another shot of
Thor inside of one of those huge
machines pulling some leavers which has
been theorized online to be a Thor Groot
and Rocket smishing throughout this
movie to build a new weapon to help take
down Thanos most people are throwing out
the idea that this is a Forge that will
help create Thor's new weapon for
infinity war which has been teased
through toys Stormbreaker
mmm he looks so cool can't wait to see
what kind of weapons Stormbreaker turns
out to be our penultimate shot before
cutting that black has a lot of fans
worried now we see Iron Man presumably
holding back
star-lord who seems to be very upset
this thing looks sleep taking place on
Titan Thanos his homeworld my guess
someone just got very hurt or possibly
died
could it be though this one is tough we
know based on previous clips of who is
on Titan to fight Thanos and his army
that's a Doctor Strange Spider Man Iron
Man's star-lord Drax and possibly nebula
from another shot my guest Thanos or the
Black Order has killed one of our
guardians either one
we could lose Gamora because that would
elicit a strong emotional response from
Peter quill since they have that whole
sexual tension subplot that's been
building through the both Guardian
movies but I'm not so sure that they
knows could kill his favorite daughter
his words my second theory and more
likely in my opinion I'm thinking Drax
since his mission originally was to get
revenge for his dead wife and daughter
by killing Ronan for then he discovered
that Thanos was actually the real power
behind his family's death he now has a
new mission which lines up pretty well
with his comic book counterpart who was
specifically written to kill thanos Drax
the destroyer who's he gonna destroy
Thanos those are just theories though
you let me know what you think last shot
of this teaser is of Thanos walking on
Titan with debris falling behind him
which is probably after he pulled a
freaking moon down but I had a question
for you guys we were shown a lot of
flashbacks to previous MCU movies do you
think this was just to make us feel
nostalgic because this movie's probably
gonna be really sad for a bunch of
characters or do you think this maybe
ties back to a fan theory that we might
be doing some time travel in this movie
courtesy of the time stone let me know
your theories down below be sure to LIKE
share and subscribe for more Marvel
breakdowns check out my MCU rewatch
breakdowns on almost all done with those
the Civil War breakdown just went up
this is a good one in my opinion not
trying to be cocky I'm AB Sam Baxter on
Twitter check out all of our other
breakdowns in shows and I'll see you
next time